[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but
eleanor is a um postdoc at university
liverpool
in media studies um
and uh one of the things just by
introduction one of the things that
i was interested to sort of observe as i
came to mit uh compared media studies
not as a
media scholar but as a pr practitioner
was all the ways in which the field here
certainly at mit was
rooted in the work of sort of
communications engineers
um that that that many of the roots of
some of the media studies were in the
work actually of engineers
and i particularly think about that in
the way that the concept of signal and
noise which is so
relevant in our work sort of had its
origins um
in that field um and what's so
intriguing about
elder's book to me at least is the ways
in which
she points out that even as media
scholars have
been getting someone
anyway the ways in which media scholars
have tended to focus on sigma on the um
signal
um and so she's taken an interest in her
work she's taking an interesting look at
the noise
um and the other uh thing that i'm
struck by uh eleanor in your
in your work is the focus on sound as um
as a metaphor we frequently the ways in
which we use metaphors around
seeing and you're suggesting that we use
more metaphors around sound so
um so i'm really intrigued to hear what
you what you have to say i'm sure
everyone else
here is too so with that i will simply
hand the floor over to you
so great so thank you very much scott
i'm gonna do the share screening part
before we start um
so thank you very much uh for this
introduction and as you said
um the timing of this book was perfect
for the apocalypse
and i had my ugly cry share
of you know not being able to actually
come to boston uh but thank you so much
for giving me this opportunity
um to present to you and i'm really
looking forward to the debate
i have kind of like an hour and a bit
more but i will try to shorten
the uh presentation so
that you can have more questions um
and i'll just start so um hi everybody
and i'm gonna do
a talk about my new book media
distortions
um and you can download the book it's
open access
and you even have a playlist with dark
motives
and things like that and you can see
things that didn't come into the book
um so please go into that website
um a bit about me uh i like to go to
comic-con as you see here
uh i thought that it would be suitable
to show you um
how i always think about different kind
of bots and different kind of deviant
things
um i'm a researcher activist feminist uh
and currently i'm working on several
projects which sort of
continue what i'm going to talk about
today around data literacies
um i'm going to talk about that a bit
more towards the end of the
um but i also want to talk about my
background i used to be a radio
broadcaster
of uh psychedelic trans i used to edit
television channels
i used to be a journalist of electronic
dance music culture
uh and write about that um and i wrote a
book my previous book was about the
israeli psychedelic trans culture
so for me sound has always been a way to
think
and examine things through so i think
this is quite
important into sort of the introduction
of
this book origin story if you may um
so why focus on the deviant
you ask um which is i think something
that
um for me i i always was very attracted
to that so even if you think about the
israeli psychedelic trans culture
that was a culture that was sort of
deviant in the israeli culture
and i was always intrigued on how
different kind of things get categorized
as
deviant so for me
part of the part of the um power
of examining things that are a bit in
the outskirts a bit
uh called deviant is to really
understand the politics of drawing these
kind of boundaries
of what is deviant and by understanding
what is the deviant we can understand
what is the norm
much better so we can in in my book and
and in my research i always try to
understand
who created these kind of categories of
what is legitimate and what is
illegitimate
why and with what russia now did they do
that who does this category serve
and um how do these categories affect
the way that we engage with media and
technology
um i also question what is a media
phenomenon so when i started my phd
um which this book is based on a lot of
people said oh but this is you know this
is marketing or this is advertising or
this is computer science
and actually people thought oh you know
we know what is spam it's like
emails about viagra and nigerian princes
and for me one of the main maybe
points to take from my book is to
question these kind of things that we
take for granted
whether it is different kind of terms
that we think or different kind of
definitions of things
um and as media scholars i think it's
really important for us to not take for
granted
what computer scientists tell us that
things are
um but also what you know marketers or
advertisers tell us things are
so this was kind of my standpoint and
also of course to examine these kind of
boring things or
these kind of things that are common
sense or taken for granted
so in the book um i look at i examine
three case studies i'm going to focus on
one today
um but i encourage you to read the book
and you'll see all the others
and what is really important for me is
that when we're talking about these kind
of deviant media categories they're
they keep on changing and evolving so i
focus on noise in the early 20th
centuries with bell telephone as one of
the biggest media company of the time
and how they sort of structure different
kind of territories and people's
behavior
uh then i focus on spam which is
the sort of the end of the 90s and early
2000s
and then i focus on facebook and how
they categorize antisocial behavior
so what is important for me to say is
that um
i think some of the problems for us as
media scholars is that the sort of the
our media
our research objects keep on changing
very fast and i think
one of the things to take from from
these kind of things is the bigger
questions right like
we're probably some of us are doing
research on facebook
which hopefully wouldn't exist in a
decade but what do we actually take from
the questions that we want to ask within
facebook
and this is something that is also very
important for me to to emphasize that
um media is gonna come and go but
the kind of larger questions of how
different kind of categories
shape our uh behavior is something
that's really important for me to
to examine so in a nutshell
my book is about media power however
most of the times when we think about
media power and most of the sort of the
theories that we have around it and
especially when we talk about the
internet
uh but also outside the internet is you
know you take the michelle
foucault's panopticon which uses very
visual
um concepts about what we can see and
what we can see
and but also what's really important
about the pan option is the architecture
has a huge
um element in this kind of media power
um theory we also have a lot of
different kind of terms when we
talk about these things we talk about
vision invisibility when we talk about
algorithms
or ai and different kind of things like
that and of course let's not forget
frank
squala's book about the black box and
what i sort of sort of
um realized as i was examining
uh my research and if you see i just now
i almost
said i saw so it's kind of uh crazy how
ingrained these kind of visual concepts
are uh in our terminology and how we
think and how we explain different kind
of things so
when i was writing the book i had to
change different kind of words into
sound concepts
that made me realize how ingrained it is
and how we think and engage with
so one of the so these are the kind of
things that i i felt that
uh are missing within the visual
frameworks which is
when we're talking about these kind of
power relations between media companies
uh we're talking about multiplicities
we're talking about multiple actors
multiple spaces multiple times multiple
purposes of conducting listenings and
rhythms which i'm going to talk about
shortly uh and different kind of
architectures
so what vision doesn't really allow us
is to sort of
uh go between the boundaries of spaces
and usually when i do this kind of talk
i do this kind of experiment where i
show that you know if i'm gonna shout
it's gonna pass the walls but my vision
is kind of constraint within time and
space
so my uh the theoretical approach that i
developed is
influenced by multiple um
other approaches such as media theory
and we're going to talk about it a bit
later
science and technology studies software
studies feminist technoscience
critical legal studies and of course
sound studies and it's really important
for me to emphasize that i used
grounded theory which means that i
didn't really assume that i
i know all these things in advance and
it's sort of these kind of things
came up as i was examining the material
that i was
um doing research on
so these are the kind of sonic
epistemologies and i'm going to
come back to that a bit later and for
the people who are reading my
book and maybe noticed each chapter
each of the the show of the case studies
is divided the first
half of the book is dedicated to the
sort of the structuring of territories
which is the ruth media
and then the second part to the process
listening so
um what i am what i'm trying to say with
these uh
things is that i am taking a different
kind of um
approaches and i'm showing how power
relations are constructed
with these two concepts which i'm gonna
talk about shortly
um and i'm gonna start with the first
one
process listening uh when we're talking
about scientists and technology most of
when we're talking about knowledge
production we usually we usually hear
about
um theories that use uh vision concepts
however there are sound um uh theories
who have been using
um sound as a way to sort of understand
and to produce knowledge so
one of the main sort of theories that
has been produced was uh
by alexandra supper and colleen
weistervelt from
the netherlands and they're talking
about different kind of practitioners
who produce knowledge so for example
doctors when they listen to you with a
stethoscope
or uh car mechanics who listen to the
car
and how they make that different kind of
diagnosis
in order to understand what's happening
with different kind of
bodies so they make this kind of
classification of different kind of
modes of listening
and how these kind of practitioners make
their assumption and then
make different kind of claims whether a
body is healthy
or is it a malfunction or different kind
of things like that
what i noticed when we're talking about
the online environment or a mediated
environment
these kind of modes of listening are
not enough because we uh engage with
different kind of
uh environment therefore um i
developed a new mode of listening which
is called process
listening it is a mode of listening
whereby practitioners you can come from
different kind of
professions and interests listen to
different kind of
sources with different kind of tools in
different times
in order to produce different kind of
knowledges and by knowledges
i mean different kind of
so for example uh when facebook um
listens to our behavior through
different kind of cookies and pixels
they create a different kind of profile
on us and then they can rearrange the
platform in different ways
to make interventions in our tempo
spatula experience
and this is what i mean by with media
now when i was talking about when i was
trying to examine how
different kind of media companies uh
shape the way the different kind of
information is uh flowing or not
um i realize that people use different
kind of concepts like flow
data streams uh data traffic and
channeling
and what i realize is that these
concepts don't really
explain to you the politics behind
how different kind of information or
different kind of connection
uh is uh made possible or unpossible to
us
so i was very influenced by
as i said before a different kind of
media theorist especially raymond
williams and his
concept of plant flow um i was also
influenced by feminist techno science by
their notion of process
and of course henry le favre a rhythm
analysis
and basically what all of the combined
uh concepts are saying
is that when all of these companies uh
whether it's facebook or i'm gonna
shortly talk about the online
advertising industry
when they listen to you through
different kind of instruments in order
to create a profile
they then create different kind of
architectures that are changing
according to that profile so the way
that we
engage with platforms uh have a
different kind of ordering
uh rhythm which is influenced by
different kind of political
decisions that are usually influenced by
advertising logic and obviously
um money so
unlike for example if i'm a doctor and i
listen to your body
in one session and that event has a
beginning and an end
when different kind of platforms or you
know web uh
and online advertisers listen to our
behavior
there isn't a beginning or end so for
example if
facebook listens to me it's not like oh
now i know everything there is to know
about eleanor by
uh the 22nd of october 2020 and i don't
need to listen to her behavior anymore
because there is an ongoing process of
listening to my behavior
in order to have a richer profile and
then
this profile is then helping these kind
of companies to create different kind of
architectures that are arranged in a
specific way to make me
engage more or to make me click on a
specific ad
or to make me maybe um sort of
comment on different kind of
inflammatory um
posts and things like that so with ruth
media what i'm trying to say
is that is the way that media companies
reorder different kind of components
in a way that orchestrates desired
rhythm so they
with this kind of ordering they decide
what is sociality
while filtering out problematic rhythms
which they define
as either noise or spam or antisocial
behavior
so these kind of practitioners they
conduct the way that mediated
architectures
change according to the knowledge that
they gain from process listening
to people's bodies across multiple
spaces
now if this sounds a bit confusing then
don't worry i'm going to give i'm going
to go into the
one of my case studies now
so um in the end of the 1990s and
and i just want to say that i decided
it's really hard you know when you write
a book and you want to talk about
everything and you can't
you know you don't really know what to
decide to focus on i really wanted to
just to focus on the standardization of
web metrics which is the end of the
1990s and the beginning of 2000s because
i think that everything that we
experienced today
around profiling around fake news around
disinformation and misinformation
and basically the problematic and broken
online ecosystem where we are the
product
started in those times so i think a lot
of the times
you know people talk only about the last
decade but we're talking about processes
that happened
probably 20 years and probably even
before but i think it's really important
to identify
key moments where these kind of things
which is
basically the surveillance of our online
behavior have become normalized
so in this case study i'm basically
looking at how did the standardization
of web metrics happen
which means how to measure different
kind of behaviors in order
to trade them in an efficient way
so as you can see here the ib which is
the
interactive advertising bureau i wanted
to standardize different kind of metrics
because in those times if you remember
um the internet wasn't really the web
wasn't really
a technology which was uh sort of
that people knew that it's gonna succeed
so a lot of the time we take
for granted that the internet is
succeeding but actually in those times
that the kind of subscription model
didn't quite work and with the dot-com
bubble crash
people didn't really know what to do and
therefore different kind of com
specific companies managed to survive
the dot-com bubble crush including
amazon
and then different kind of platforms
started to emerge which gave a free
service whereas
you know as we all know it wasn't quite
free but we were the products so let's
see what happened in those
days so with this kind of um uh
the ib wanted to actually understand how
can we standardize different kind of
measuring units how can we standardize
how we measure people's behavior
in order to make this kind of product
which is our behavior
as efficient as possible because if we
are the product
then the kind of the currency needs to
be agreed upon with all of the actors
that are
involved so as you can see here these
were the most
uh sort of common um
[Music]
metrics um and
what they basically wanted to understand
is how are they gonna measure it
through different kind of uh angles will
it be through the
ad serving will it be through people's
computer and what will actually count as
a click what will count as a total visit
and what will count as an ad impression
now
for me one of the most interesting thing
that was part of this research
was uh to actually analyze different
kind of
internet standards through the ietf
which is the internet engineering task
force
um and also i analyze different kind of
legal documents in order to understand
how do they actually decide
what's happening there so when i was
starting to
read the cookie standard which is what
you're looking at here
i started to realize that actually
what's happening in the back end
is that when you visit the website uh
you through different kind of default
settings
you are being sent a lot of cookies
which could be dozens of cookies
hundreds of cookies in order to
basically
send different kind of information about
your behavior
if it's from the website that you type
on that would be first party cookie so
that means that
you know if for example i look at the
guardian um
then it will be a first party cookie
that the guardian collects
information on me but if it's
third-party cookies it could be ad
exchanges or different kind of data
brokers who
are also gonna sort of listen to my
behavior
across different kind of platforms and
throughout
time so what i basically saw here is
that there is a standard
and we're actually not really aware of
what's happening
what was really interesting with this
standard is that the people who
suggested it at the beginning said well
actually maybe we will
show part of the standard will be to
show to people what's happening in the
back end because people don't really
understand
that all of these these things are
happening and the advertising industry
at that time said no no no
it's going to confuse people so let's
just show them you know
the front end as computer scientists
call it
so that it wouldn't confuse them to see
what's happening in the back end
um but actually when we think about
cookies and one of the things that
struck me is that all of the people who
are talking about cookies
whether it's computer scientists or even
media scholars they call it
just a text file but this just a text
file
is actually a communication form because
what cookies actually do
is to plant different kind of text files
but every time that you make these kind
of
whether i'm reading an article or i'm
clicking on things
these kind of things are communicated to
different kind of
entities and those can be either as i
said before the guardian if it's first
party cookies
or it could be other data brokers or
different kind of agencies
which we are not aware of so this is
when i was talking about sort of
um not going into the common sense or
the common way of defining different
things this is
one of these moments where i realized
that actually you know we've been sold
that cookies are just
text file this is also part of a
legislation
um that's going on behind it
but actually it's a form of
communication because they're
communicating different kind of topics
which could be
my gender the kind of device that i'm
using the kind of
a broadband that i'm using and different
kind of things
throughout time so
one of the other things that the
advertising industry
wanted to do was because there was all
of these kind of
robotic behavior they wanted to
understand
who is human and who is not human
because it was really important for them
if we are the product
it's important to have exact
measurements
so what they did was to develop this
different kind of measure measurements
and what they called filtration in order
to filter
who is human and who is not human in
order to make
accurate measurements of what is
happening so that they can trade us
so as you can see here they develop
different kind of so for example the
basic method which was a text file of
robots the other one was identification
of specific suspicious and non-human
activity
which was a different kind of list that
you were supposed to send to iab
and another thing was to analyze the
rhythms
of users activity which i found really
interesting because what they were
basically
defining there is what are the kind of
behaviors that are
can be considered as robotic and hence
non-human
and what are the kind of behaviors that
can be defined as humans
and as you can see here these are the
kind of uh
definitions that they had of uh
what is a robotic behavior so sort of
what did they analyze in order to to
establish that so they established what
users performing multiple sequential
activities
users with highest levels of activities
users who acted in consistent
interaction attributes
and other suspicious activities
so what they were doing with that is
basically not only
to try to understand to measure people
but also to define
what is a human and non-human behavior
and for me actually one of the first
times that i realized that was in my
first book when i
published it um all of the people that i
interviewed i
invited them to come to a launch event
so that i can interview them
and i sent them all the same message on
facebook
because i was frankly a bit lazy and i
just changed their name
and after a while i didn't hear from a
lot of them and i was really offended i
was like
i interviewed you and you can at least
tell me you know yes or no or something
and then one of them who works in the
music industry tell me oh did you send
the same
format of message and i was like yes and
he was like oh
well facebook then will think that you
are a bot
or a spammer of some kind and then it
will send your message
into the other folder which could be you
know the spam folder or the junk folder
um because they analyzed your behavior
and this is a you know
a sequential activity and with the same
activity
you maybe just change the name so that
was something that triggered
my my sort of thought of like how these
companies
are making these kind of uh decisions of
which kind of behavior is legitimate
and which kind of behavior is
illegitimate and then shapes our
behavior accordingly
because what he told me that label
manager is that
he of course has the same kind of
messages he changes them
in a way that will try to avoid this
kind of being called the spammer
so this this was the the sort of
analyzing the internet
standards part here i'm showing you how
in the european union
when they were trying to make
legislation around the electronic
communication that was starting to be
more popular at the time
how did they actually define that and
how did the advertising industry you
lobbied um the european union
how did they manage to bypass that so
what you're looking at now is the spam
article
from the electronic uh directive from
2002
and the way that they define it is the
use of automated calling and
communication system without human
intervention
um for the purposes of direct marketing
and may only be allowed in respective
subscribers having given their prior
consent
if you're european you probably know but
the prior consent i'm going to talk
about it
shortly but we know
that there are a lot of different kind
of activities which we
consider as part of that so for example
if you remember the horrible
uh spam attack that we got uh you two
into
youtube and into our computer without
being asked without our prior consent
and then you know when apple was talking
about that they said oh well actually
with article two of that law it means
that
once you have some kind of connection
with
a company then that makes it an informed
consent and informed consent or interned
or implicit consent means that
uh if you have any kind of interaction
with this company
then you are in a kind of weird
relationship where you can
uh you you are allowed to send these
people these kind of
um marketing um
things and during the end of the 90s and
the beginning of the 2000s
there were a lot of debates of whether
you know cookies should be legitimized
and what's happening there and
this is this is an article that i really
like from 2001 on the left hand side
where um uh the chairman of the iab
united kingdom
says cookies have been branded as
spyware tools or some kind of subversive
software
but it's what we use every day and i
think it's quite telling that this is
20 years ago where even then people
understood that
you know cookies and pixels and all
these things are basically spyware
and doing this kind of surveillance over
our everyday activities
um but the kind of normalization that it
happened throughout the years i think is
is something that we
need to remember that happened with the
kind of the lobbying of the advertising
industry that managed to make it
seem as if it's it's nice and friendly
even with the name when you think about
cookies
um so actually according to the law
both cookies and spam are the exact same
thing
because both of them are sent through
automated
systems they are meant for direct
marketing and they are sent without our
prior consent
but it was really important for the
advertising industry to make a
difference
between legitimate advertising practices
and illegitimate advertising practices
in order to standardize what was
starting to be
the online uh data broker online
ecosystem that we know today
so part of what we understand and we
know today is the real time bidding
which is happening in the back end of
our screens
and we don't know about it because as i
said before the
advertising industry lobbied for us not
to understand what's happening in the
back end
and basically facebook and a lot of
these companies including google
they basically took this standard of
real-time bidding and developed it
into their own different kind of systems
um so when i was talking before about
these kind of
when i was talking about why should we
use sound concepts
is exactly these kind of multiplicities
of actors
who listen to us throughout time so we
have so many companies
who are listening to our behavior in the
back end it could be facebook it could
be google it could be amazon it could be
you know your uh your government
it could be different kind of data
brokers that we're not aware of
and these companies are then uh trading
uh
these data without our understanding or
consent
so as i said before this was part of the
politics around that
is to create these kind of architectures
where
we don't really understand what's
happening and part of the
sort of one of the ways that um uh
the sort of the people who developed the
standards said oh you know we're not
gonna make it visible but people can
still change the cookie setting
in somewhere in the setting of the
browsers and this is part of the
politics that i'm talking about
arranging the architecture in a way that
it will be difficult for us to actually
engage in it
in a meaningful way and i thought that
it was quite funny because today
when i wanted to uh post uh uh um
sort of advertise this on my facebook i
used a different kind of browser
and then facebook asked me if i want to
accept all cookies
so if you look on the left hand side we
have a lot of choice here we can either
accept all
which facebook obviously wants us to
choose because it signals it
in blue and then if you you want to
manage the data settings
you go to the picture in the in the
right side and as you can see
the only way that i can engage with
facebook is by
accepting cookies there is literally no
way
for me to decline to negotiate to say
maybe i want these cookies maybe i don't
want those cookies
and for me this is this is part of what
what i'm trying to say with my book is
how these kind of companies
structure specific architecture where we
basically have one way to experience
them
and facebook of course is not the only
one we also have
google uh and amazon and all of these
companies
but i think it's really important for us
to understand that we are presented
with one way of experiencing them and
and then we don't see what actually
happening in the back end so what you're
seeing here
some of these um devices do not exist
anymore the light bleem which was
connected uh to firefox in the middle
um on the left you see privacy badger
and on the right is the uk
sort of ad blocker and what i want to
show here i don't know if you managed to
see that there are
hundreds of cookies that are plugged
into
my device and this is i think for me
one of the most amazing things of the
most amazing exercises i usually do with
my students of advertising students who
don't even realize
what is happening in the back end and
once i show them that
i'll most of them are quite shocked and
i think a lot of them are
like why why didn't we know this before
and
how how can we do something different
and i think
for me this is again part of the bigger
politics where
our computer screen or our you know
a phone screen creates this kind of
divide
of power relations where
in the front end we get a very kind of
pristine architecture and interface
where we can engage with these platforms
if you're living in the eu
you might get all of the choice of
pressing i accept i agree or okay
but then in the back end we have a whole
other
online uh market that is
trading us in milliseconds and
so this kind of the boundary of our
screen is not only
with uh with what's happening uh in
terms of
it's a division of what is human and
what is non-human also because what's
happening in the backend is something
that we can't even comprehend
so once we upload a certain webpage
or facebook this these kind of the
trading and the bidding
on our profiles happens within
milliseconds
so our screen creates uh this kind of
estimate the boundary of the asymmetric
power
that these kind of big technology
companies or the data brokers have
of us so and this is
uh what happens is that these kind of
ads keep on chasing us
uh and this is i really recommend you to
see a south park they had a i think in
the 19th season
where they were criticizing uh online
ads and sort of how it
kind of chases you and from my research
that i'm doing
these days where we try to sort of
understand people's data literacies
one of the things that we keep on
getting from people is that
not only do people don't really
understand what's happening with their
data
a lot of the time when they're
expressing these kind of concerns and
fears from advertisements
is that they keep on seeing the same ads
and in a certain amount of time they say
okay then
after i'm seeing it so many times i'm
gonna press
that ad just so it would leave me alone
so i think what we're seeing here is
these kind of ordering of the
architecture and what we kind of can
engage with
uh in a specific time in space and
how that basically shapes our behavior
and that can also be
in the shape of how different kind of
companies
push us different kind of disinformation
and misinformation
so i think only now we start to get this
kind of critical debates of how
facebook keeps on you know pushing
different kind of problematic material
but actually pushing problematic
material from facebook is part of their
business model because the more
emotional material will be on their
platform the more that you will engage
so it does
it doesn't matter for them if it's a
picture of your family
uh in an awkward position or if it's
disinformation
or conspiracy theories because it's all
part of fueling more engagement
and more comments between people
so i'm going to push
more towards what's happening these days
and sort of to show you that
today activists um are pushing
and i think that there is this kind of
um
reckoning of this kind of power relation
and
what these companies are doing we're
seeing the ftc
wants to start investigating real-time
bidding these days
um actually i think last week or or a
week and a half ago
activists show that the whole consent
framework is actually flawed
of the ad tracking um industry um so we
are starting to see a lot of changes
but the main problem is that the way
that we
experience the internet today is that
these companies want us to feel that
this is the only way that you can
experience these platforms and it can
only be through
you know my own profile that you know
not many people for example can use one
profile
or that it could only be with cookies
or it can only be through you know this
kind of
uh ongoing surveillance and so for me
one of the main things about
sort of peeling off these kind of layers
of politics
and how these companies have lobbied and
tried to create these kind of
architectures is to show that actually
all of these things were strategies that
were ongoing
by these companies so that also means
that we can also
build you know different kind of
platforms and different kind of things
in a different way
but in order to do that and this is sort
of relates to what i'm working on now
is that people actually are not aware of
what is happening in the back end and as
i said this was
a planned strategy but people do not
understand the political economy of the
internet so they don't know
most people do not know that google and
facebook are funded
by mostly that their main income comes
from advertising
most people don't understand how
algorithms profiling
you know web cookies most people don't
understand how they work
i can even say further that i'm doing
focus groups
this month and when we ask people even
what is
basic thing like what is data what is
the thing that
you know that these companies maybe uh
know about you and things like that
most of these people have no idea so
i think that in order to to create a
change in order to understand what is
happening
and even more so in order to demand
different kind of future
we actually need to go to the basics and
actually explain to people
what is happening and i think
unfortunately a lot of people
have seen the social dilemma um and
you know keep on texting me and saying
oh you should see that even my mom tell
you
only now i realize what's really
happening which is good and bad because
obviously that documentary could have
been
um much better and i have a whole
twitter and uh if you want to see that
about that
but um i think what it actually shows is
that
the way that we communicate that whether
scholars
or journalists or activists we kind of
assume that people know
about these things and a lot of the time
we kind of talk from a very
sort of top-down kind of approach and
i feel that we actually need to go to
the basics and actually explain to
people
what is happening in order for them to
demand
different kind of platforms and to
understand what are the consequences
of that so i actually wanted to show you
part of that and this is part of the
research that i'm doing right now
where we ask people um on the left-hand
side you see
how much do you agree that people that
companies would use their personal
information to personalize your
experience
and you can see here according to
different kind of groups more or less
they
they don't really agree but some of them
do
but when we actually ask them if they
accept that companies would use their
personal information to track their
behavior over time you can see here
unanimously that
most people don't agree with that and
the fact that people don't make these
kind of connections that personalization
and tracking over time is the same kind
of thing
is actually a clear sort of evidence
that shows that people actually have no
idea what's happening
and they don't make these kind of
connections so when you don't know
what's happening you can't really demand
that you will have a different kind of
future
and while i believe that you know as
academics a lot of us are doing really
important work
uh in sort of advancing the debate we
actually
need to to go to the basics and to to
make people understand
so um i'm gonna switch that and i'm
gonna i think
uh go straight to the end and say that
um
deviant media categories are about the
struggles to determine
what is human what is normal and what is
social
is about what makes us as individuals in
society it is about the default settings
of our lives and if we want to change
the default settings of our lives or at
least to have
several options of default settings then
we need to sort of peel off these kind
of um
strategies that were constructed
throughout time to make these divisions
of what is deviant and what is not
deviant
so i think i even managed to finish
before
time because i was talking really fast
so
there you go
i'm gonna stop sharing
great thank you very much
that was fascinating let's um see
whether right off whether we have any
questions
um
i don't see a handout um
i guess one of the things i'll start
with a question uh
which is um i know some of your work you
looked at sort of practices
sort of um outside of norms um
are you seeing media prac
are you seeing communities of um
attempting to sort of circumvent these
systems in their media practice
um in any interesting ways
i think that um a while ago i
saw that several teenagers are using the
same instagram account
in order to bypass different kind of
profiling
um and i know that um a lot of activists
are also doing stuff around that but i
think
um you know there's a lot of different
kind of people who are trying to
um object in other ways uh
so we have max trams for example who is
an activist who's trying to change
things from the legal aspect which i
think is quite
important crucial because um
you know you need to have several kind
of battles going on at the same time
um i think people are also trying to
create different kind of
alternatives to facebook and you know
and twitter
um i don't know how how effective it is
but i
also obviously don't think that there is
only one way if if we want to change the
way that things are i think that we need
to go
through multiple directions so i think
you know on the one hand having more
sort of different kind of education and
dental literacy program
is one way another way is to try and
change
uh the legal frameworks that we have
today which are completely not equipped
to uh combat these kind of companies we
i don't know if you saw a couple of days
ago
that uh the ethic ftc is uh gonna have a
huge antitrust against google
which is great but what is it actually
gonna do
um is it actually tackling the main
issue which is the business model no
it's just saying oh maybe we'll you know
dissect google into even smaller pieces
um and also as you can see um
all of these sort of measurements are
coming
after a really long time which these
companies already managed to cement
themselves
as a huge um an inseparable part from
our lives
so for me one of the main things is that
actually
we need to have um more
uh uh public spaces uh which could
potentially come from
government funding it could come from
maybe have an internet tax
or different kind of things like that
where we will have
um other options than the big companies
um it's not a perfect solution like any
kind of solution
but you know it could be a start rather
than counting on google or
facebook to to do everything that we
need basically
today i hope it answered
the question is emily did you
um yeah yeah i uh so i've i have to
admit i've only watched i think about
half
of the social dilemma um but i'm just
curious to know if you
had the platform of moviemaking to
spread your message how would you have
uh
changed the way the message was people
about these things
so if you could like recreate the social
blendline your own terms what would you
have wanted to
depict i'm happy that you're asking that
emily because i'm just planning to
actually submit to netflix so if netflix
is watching this i'm open to get all of
the funding that you want to give me
uh but no but seriously i am i thought
about that i think
one of the main issue for me in that
documentary
is is several things first of all asking
the tech bros to answer
the the problems that the tech bros have
created
for me is a huge issue um there is
there are a lot of smart people both in
academia both
underground you know activists who've
been dealing with these things for
for years who haven't been asked um and
another thing is that
um although i like the us and i think a
lot of amazing things are happening in
the us
these companies are global so if we keep
on you know only focusing on the us
issue it sort of recreates the the
problem right because
a lot of the the standards of these
companies when we think about content
moderation
a lot of the laws that sort of govern
that comes from a u.s
focus and u.s centered mindset and i
think it's quite important to
have a different kind of perspective of
how
these kind of companies shape i would
definitely also
focus on uh chinese companies
uh and weibo and different kind of
things like that um
and also show i think more historical
perspective
but i think that um yeah i would
definitely also not do it
uh a one film documentary because i
think you if you're trying to shove
so many things in one program that sort
of means that you're
losing a lot of things so i am thinking
of doing
a series uh and
um yeah and just to consult with people
who have been dealing with it in
different parts of the world
and to get a richer understanding of how
these technologies affect different kind
of communities
different kind of regions and not to
necessarily assume that
all of the people who actually created a
problem can actually have
uh more insights than people who have
been dealing with it in different kind
of
ways and aspects um that would be
my approach and again netflix if you
wanna i'm available
on email and yeah thanks if you need any
petitioners for this series let me know
i will
no i'm serious i was actually uh um
dming a lot of people this week saying
i i can't stand having all of this these
documentaries and having my mom tell me
oh did you see the social dilemma
it's so important i learned so much and
i was like
yes mom but so you know
i think this is part of something that i
think that academics need to be
we need to communicate more because i
think there's a lot of really important
and great work that's happening in
academia but a lot of the time
it's really difficult for us to
communicate it so i think that we need
to have better routes to communicate
stuff you know a lot of the things that
are happening with facebook
we've been talking about them for a
decade if not even more right and
everybody's
keeps on being surprised every time and
actually
um so that means that basically we need
a better
communication channel between journalism
and way to communicate with
you know everyday people in order for
them to relate with what we're talking
about
basically
yes vivec thank you
eleanor for a really great talk um
that taps into all of my
my existing paranoias and
and and you know having been involved i
was
um involved in the like web
1.0 really in the 1990s as a html
coder right and so that i know that all
these conversations all these concerns
have been there ever since the beginning
right yeah but that they but that they
haven't been as you're saying about the
social dilemma
that you know these voices have not been
listened to and the people who
are in that film um knew all of this too
i mean that you know because it was it
was all
there right yeah um but my my question
is actually about
um uh it goes to some of the the work
that you've been doing
um the interview based research that
you've been doing
um and you showed us one slide with
um uh people whether they are okay
with their information being tracked in
these different yeah
um and i guess you know
part of what i'm curious about is
whether you're also
approaching those questions in terms of
of
trade-off and and what people are
willing to trade off and i'm thinking
about this
in terms of the really um you know
draconian
um uh surveillance that that followed
911
right and it and for those who were in
the communities being surveilled it was
a horrific
moment and and you know continues to be
so because it kind of
shifted the way that that
that the state is allowed to surveil
different communities
but for a lot of people who are not part
of the surveilled communities
it was this question of trade-off well
if i'm safer i don't mind if
if i'm being tracked and surveilled
because i know that i'm not
the person who's being targeted right
and so actually this is for my own
benefit
and so in the case of um the
logic of the logic that has been sold
about
cookies and other kinds of tracking
devices is that
um you know this is for your own good so
that we can
um you know we can give you uh
serve to you the kinds of things that
you want to see
the kinds of products you want to buy
etc
and it's just a matter of you know you
just have to trade off
a certain amount of privacy for this
benefit
and so i'm just wondering about like how
that
um plays into or has played into
the kinds of conversations or interviews
that you've done with people
um i think it's really interesting what
you're saying here and i had a focus
group actually today
and a lot of people said that you know
that they were concerned about different
kind of privacy
related issues but then with you know
the pandemic happening
they didn't really feel that they have a
choice and i think that the the
non-choice
factor here is is quite huge because a
lot of services that we have today are
digital
there's actually very few services today
that you can do
non-digitally so there's actually not
really a choice here
you're not really being asked if if you
can or cannot do things
and what a lot of these companies did
they basically changed the nature
of this kind of contract with people
right so
you have these kind of different kind of
terms of use or different kind of
um contracts basically where they say
what are they going to do with your data
i'm probably one of the few people who
actually read these uh
terms and views when i can not always
because i try to have a life
and you know that sort of creates um
again these kind of asymmetric power
relations because what are you actually
trading
do you actually know what you're trading
and i think a lot of the time
you know we're being told that we should
feel safe or you know that this is okay
but actually it's not only to sell you
different kind of data
and we can't it's really difficult to
trust these kind of companies because
as time goes on we realize that actually
you know i thought that i'm giving my
data
just to get to the guardian but actually
i give it to the guardian and i give it
to a lot of other data brokers who maybe
are then going to sell me a problematic
maybe
life insurance or different kind of
things like that or maybe it can harm
different kind of you know job
opportunities or things that we actually
can't really understand and predict
right now because one of the problems is
that this data as i said with process
listening one of the main things that i
wanted to emphasize with that
is that it's an ongoing process so i
actually have no idea
who has my data how much time are they
going to keep it
how are they going to use it for how
long and different kind of things like
that
so i agree with you that you know if it
was in the fair world or in a in in the
previous world when we knew that we're
making this kind of
uh transaction or kind of a
way to say okay i'm just gonna uh
give you a bit of my data and then
you're gonna
do it with that but actually one of the
things that i'm i'm
trying to argue in in the in the book is
that there's actually no negotiation
here right
like you have one way as you saw with
facebook i can only press
accept all or i accept and why actually
can't we negotiate
why can't i negotiate individually with
each of the platforms
what do i want to do why can't i have a
bar on the side that i can see
which kind of data is going on and
believe me that i'm not going to get
confused because i'm sure that all of
you
at this moment have at least 20 tabs
open
with like a bazillion other things
happening so
i think that you know we need to think
about these things differently
and i agree with you that while some
people think that you know
it's great i'm gonna get personalized
you know i'm gonna get
you know maybe a gin that i always
wanted to to buy and
occasionally i do get like really good
ads but i
i can't even know what is the the
trade-off here
because it's so opaque to me i have no
idea what's happening in the back end
i have no idea who who is involved and
that is what's troubling to me and
what's traveling to a lot of
activists and scholars is that this kind
of like this kind of a screen that
basically separates
between me and all of the other
companies that can listen to my behavior
so uh while i do agree with you that
sometimes the trade-off is
is okay the the sort of the all the
possibilities that it could be
misused or abused is is very high
and so we need to both think about how
we're going to regulate these companies
but also how we create a fairer
kind of trade-off here actually maybe i
do want to
negotiate with you just like i wouldn't
have an open-ended
contract with my landlord who maybe
tomorrow decide that they
want to crash in my place in the living
room so
these are the kind of things that i'm
thinking about i hope it answered
yeah thanks and and i agree with you um
my question was more about
the you know how do we change a kind of
broad acceptance uh you know
among you know as part of part of the
the
activist work yeah um you know how
how to change a kind of or
create a broad consciousness that the
trade-off is no trade-off i think one of
the so
again it's it's about data literacies
and it's about
um about these very basic things
um unfortunately the way that um media
and computers are being taught we're not
really being taught about
basic things like the online economy uh
what are cookies and what are all of
these kind of things and part of the
project that i'm working on now
which you saw before which was the the
survey that we conducted and now we're
doing focus groups
is to create these it's called mean my
big data it's new field foundation
funded
and part of the things that we're trying
to do is to try to understand how
different kind of groups
what do they actually understand and
then how can we design education
material that actually is tailored to
different kind of people
what we saw with the the survey at least
is that
people's dental literacies are very much
influenced by education
and socio-economic condition so the more
educated you are and the richer you
are the more you know what's happening
with your data
and the more you know for example about
privacy settings and what to do there
so again we're seeing this kind of that
how these kind of platforms that
this architecture actually harms the
people who are
the most marginalized so the answer is
data literacies
in a nutshell and we have a couple
questions and or comments in the chat
but
i could read them but i'd rather if
people what is the difference between
the chat and the q
a uh the chat is the from the panelists
and the qa is just from
the attendees but um so i wanted to
and i want to get to all of them but i
wanted to first give people an option
rather than having them out loud abby
did you want to
make your statement yourself before i
read it or uh
what's your preference there
um sorry i have just done an entire day
full of zooms so i apologize for my
video
being off i'm happy to um read my
statement also turn it into a question
actually because i sort of wrote it
eleanor before you said that you would
love to make a documentary for netflix
yourself so
yes it's all the rage these days my own
background is in um
documentary film and i think a lot about
the
politics of exhibition and all of that
so for me
um what i wrote was um i'm very i'll
rephrase it too i'm pretty much i'm
pretty concerned honestly
as someone that comes from the film
distribution exhibition background
um about the platform streaming
platforms such as netflix that the
social dilemma is on
um for me the the way that these
platforms are designed um are similar
to the ways that social media platforms
keep viewers engaged
um so for me the fact that a film like
the social dilemma which is criticizing
the sort of um you know decisions that
these social media platforms make to
keep viewers uncritically engaged
are in fact the same strategies that
netflix itself uses
so if a film or a docu-series even
though i
i do have not seen the social dilemma
um because i have major problems with
the filmmaker's other work he uses a lot
of i think advertising and marketing
strategies and his works that are
extensive anyway
don't need to get into that so my
question is um
anything that's kind of critical of this
type of
the results of these types of
technological apparatuses
how they as you describe it like filter
and sort people's behaviors
um i guess i'm curious for you to talk
about your thoughts of
um whether or not anything critical of
these things can
be truly critical if it's being used
also as a piece of content
by these sorry systems i think
thanks for your question i think um uh
it's it's a really important one and i
think it is really
difficult to create content that uh
would resonate
i can tell you from my experience um i
remember
one time i was teaching my students
cookies and everything
and one day i saw all of my students
come
and cover the camera you know the laptop
camera
yes finally everything that i'm teaching
them comes through
and now they're interested and then i
asked them so why why did you cover
the the camera and all of them said oh
we saw that episode on black mirror
where you know he's you know being uh
photographed and i was like
okay okay maybe it's like halfway but i
think
things like black mirror things like
stories basically stories that we can
relate to
i think are and i'm sure as a
documentarist you know the value and the
power of stories
i think that could be our way to um
to communicate these kind of things uh
clearer
and hopefully to to make critique in an
engaging and meaningful way for people's
everyday life because i think sometimes
critique
um when we talk about it um and when we
try to communicate it
sometimes you know everyday people maybe
wouldn't be interested
or they don't really understand how it
relates to them
um so i think if we can translate a lot
of our ideas to
to these kind of stories that people can
relate to that can help
um uh sort of communicating the critique
in in a meaningful way
i hope that that answered your question
thanks thanks abby um charlton would you
like to um
yeah i'm mute good and ask your question
thank you yeah yeah i'd be happy to um
hi hey eleanor i'm so glad that you made
it to boston even if it was only at a
level i know
right thank you so much
yeah of course of course so uh this is
fascinating here i was hoping that you
would
close the circle on the talk by coming
back to
your use of sound metaphors because i
find you know the argument about
you know uh having to sort of stabilize
what counted as cookies stabilize what
counted as a human user versus
that that's all very convincing to me
the turn to
digital literacy uh for sort of you know
what people not know
uh that they don't know so uh in that
argument where did your turn to sound
help you notice something make a case
that you couldn't have otherwise
um i think that because so thanks for
the question i think when i
started the research i the first case
study
is with bell telephone and it's with
actual noise and sound
and so when i was starting the research
looking at spam
i was trying to think okay spam is this
kind of disturbance so what's actually
happening
uh there and i was trying to say so who
actually created the first sort of
communication model
and that threw me away to bell and
um and i think that sort of uh helped me
to think about the way that
the more we listen to different kind of
things but also the
more that we can listen to multiple
spaces at the same time
that creates this kind of um asymmetric
power
and so when i'm talking about cookies or
when i'm talking about facebook
has the most power by being able to
listen to my behavior
both on the platform both outside the
platform
at the same time i can't listen to my
own body
because which body i i consider to be in
my computer
it could be my laptop it could be my
phone because of this
as i said before this kind of screen
which doesn't really allow me to
understand who is listening to me so to
me
listening enables us to cross boundaries
of time and space and that means that i
can listen to your behavior
when you're on facebook when you're on
google and it's an ongoing process
um which for me we don't we can't really
uh it can't really happen when i'm
thinking about
it through vision because vision for me
is very much constrained within time and
space
but i can only be in a specific time in
space and that creates for me
a singular layer if it may
and what i realize with facebook and all
of these kind of
um companies that are listening to us is
these kind of multiplicities of layers
and as
as we as you obviously know i work
also on content moderation which we had
a very great article that came today
uh on internet policy review if you want
to see from my our aoar
panel in 2019
and there i examine content moderators
and how they listen
and so i noticed with the content
moderators
which at the time that i was examining
it it was kind of sort of new it was
2015 2014
when i was starting to engage with that
i was actually single actually there's
so many different kind of entities
whether human or
if it's funded moderators or non-human
like cookies
who are listening to our behavior um and
therefore there are these kind of
multiple spaces which i think
vision doesn't really allow us to
understand these kind of multiplicities
and for me the multiplicities are
important because they show us
how so many organizations are involved
in creating these kind of
profiles um and again this doesn't only
happen in a digital environment it also
happens as i show with the build
telephone
in an analog environment so when i was
comparing content moderators to
um telephone operators who also listened
on the line and were
you know part of the communication
channel this is part of
you know what i was trying to engage so
i hope it answered
yeah yeah i like that it's somehow it's
sometimes about
looking at actual listening practices
and sometimes it's a kind of
kind of metaphor that you use to train
yourself to notice things
i think that's i think both of those are
really interesting thank you thank you
yeah i think
for me again it's uh it's kind of an
exercise i don't
i don't mean that we need to sort of
abandon everything that
is visual and optic i just think that
there is
there are more and more scholars who are
pushing towards
uh thinking about media through
different kind of senses
there is david parisi's amazing book
about the archaeology of touch
and so i think that as scholars and what
i really like about this department
specifically as i know there's a lot of
artists
and people who are thinking critically i
think that it just opens
more you know spaces for us to think
about
what what's actually happening so it
doesn't mean that we need to completely
abandoned
vision for all the people who like
vision related concepts but it's just
another way to
examine different kind of media
phenomena thanks
thanks thomas are you uh
would you like to i'm just going to read
what i said
because i don't know so i'm following on
the idea of distortions have you
considered the scenario
of algorithmical listening to bots so
bob the algorithm listening to bots who
have algorithm algorithmical behavior
so i wonder what happens that feedback
loop and how the global
algorithm becomes distorted by the input
of algorithms
and i wonder what's the consequences the
spillovers for for human use
for human users so what is the
disruption
of when algorithms can you repeat that
i'm wondering if so you know we have
algorithmical listening right
but we also have algorithmical content
production we talked about bots we
talked about
how this algorithms produce content so
i'm interested in maybe if you consider
that feedback loop right
how the algorithm listens to
algorithmical production and what
happens is that that's an area
um i think that what's really important
for me in my research to emphasize that
it's never only machines involved or
bots involved there's always humans
in every part of the process so you know
even with platforms only
when you think about it only in the
recent years facebook has actually
confessed that there are content
moderators at the beginning they said oh
we don't know what you're talking about
and then when you know people started to
push and more and more people started to
talk about that you realize that there
are people at all of the
all of the points of automation it's
never a full automation there's always
humans there so i think that when you're
talking about that this kind of
algorithmic uh
content and also algorithmic ordering
there are always
people at different points of the
communication channel that are going to
decide
what is deviant so sort of what is
relevant for our business model and what
is not relevant for a business
model and hence will be filtered out
um so to me that is
it's really important and it's really
important for me not to talk about
algorithms in an abstract way because
then we're sort of taking away the
responsibility of the humans that are
always involved in that process
and the politics of the different kind
of humans whether they're
programmers or the ceos or if they are
the more inferior humans in this process
which are the content moderators
or you know even in google they have you
know the rankers who are
deciding how things are going to get
ranked on the google search results
so to me what i think what you're asking
involves again with this kind of
different kind of decisions made by
humans
and it's never going to be a perfect uh
kind of uh
entanglement but um
i think that the way they're going to
respond to each other is very much
related to
these kind of decisions i hope it's
answered
thank you uh we've got two questions
from the q
a and i'll read them out loud just so
that they get into the recording
the first is from radu and the idea of
surveillance and data capitalism that is
being put forward by the tech giants
nowadays
drives me to always think of gramsci and
his theory of hegemony
following gramsci strategies of changing
the systems he advocated
of people going into institutions such
as schools government offices
to change them from within would that be
possible in tech industry
would those change makers be immediately
perceived as deviant and thrown away
and then uh adds i'm sorry a long
question but i'd love this talking very
enthusiastic so
no it's fantastic please please ask and
it's great i
i really like the questions here it's
it's great that people engage
with the book um so you're basically
asking if it's the matrix and if neo
needs to
be part of the system or not um i think
that
again in order to change the way things
are i think that we need to think about
it um not is like the one solution
but as multiple solutions and of course
different kind of solutions are going to
be
more relevant in different kind of
regions so what
will be more beneficial in europe is not
going to be more beneficial
in the us or russia or asia
china israel different kind of places
i do think that a lot of people are
trying to change uh
both from within and outside
um i think that we need to have these
kind of forces
in all of the directions um i think that
at the moment the kind of instruments
that we have
as i said before you know everybody had
so many hopes with the gdpr
um if you are following and i really
recommend you to follow max trams who's
an activist who's been trying to change
a lot of things
and he has changed a lot of things um
what he showed is that even though we
have the gdpr
the kind of the dpa the the data
protection authority in different kind
of countries in europe
actually provide very little money to
actually take
care of all of the people's um sort of
lawsuits again different kind of
companies that are dealing with their
data
so um i do think that people need to
integrate both in government hopefully
also in
technology companies but also that we
need to
uh educate people so to me it's it's
multi-layered
both to to to change laws to have data
literacies
to change the way the technology
companies are operating
um and also to change the way that we
are talking about these things
whether it's with you know more
entertaining content
but also journalists um so
um yeah it's a multi multi-year
multi-step
strategy to some degree with that
answer you may have answered the
following question but of this from
hamid reza nassiri what you said about
social dilemma
isn't that actually one of the main
issues that there are these sources that
give the illusion of informing people
but they systematically ignore the
systemic problems
that make sure that the discourse
remains shaped by the powerful
institutions
the same thing that professor bald
mentioned regarding convincing people
that it's for their own security or
recently convincing people
that censorship by the big by big tech
is actually in the interest of the
people
how can one fight that kind of informing
that persuades people to act against
their own interests
while making them think that they're
actually engaging in resistance
very intense questions um i
again i don't have all the solutions i
only think that the way to make people
engage
is actually to inform them and i think
that people only
um i have a friend who's been an
activist for many years and he told me
that the things that sort of motivates
people
to go to the streets is when things hit
you the most
so in israel at the moment people are
demonstrating for the past few months
against benjamin netanyahu and his
regime
and it's not that they haven't been
demonstrating before but i think that
with the covet and the pandemic
they realize what they can lose and i
think that
this kind of when it touches your life
when you actually know what you can lose
then people are more engaged i don't
know if people saw that
um students here had a whole
demonstration against the algorithm
um so the story was that students were
supposed to
sort of graduate the high school year
they were supposed to have an exam
but because of covet of course they
couldn't have the exam
and then the government designed the
weird kind of algorithm
that made a lot of mistakes which meant
that people who came from deprived
areas received lower grades than they
should have
and then students came and started to
protest
and said you know we're having these
different kind of signs you know like
[ __ ] the algorithm and going to the
streets
and um and doing a lot of petitions
and like asking and attacking the
government and the government actually
caved and changed these results
so why did these students didn't protest
for example
when it was brexit which is a question
that i was asking quite a lot
and i think that one of the things is
that with the algorithm
you can actually see what's happening to
you it was very visible right you can
actually see how it can harm you
with with brexit we don't even know what
is the current what what are the
agreements
right so i think that if we actually
want to engage people if we want to
motivate people
to make the make these kind of different
kind of changes
we need to help them understand how that
can actually harm their everyday life
and that
i think engages people into action um
and and we have different kind of
examples like these
you know it's funny i followed that from
a distance and i kept thinking it's
great that they're
protesting but shouldn't they be
protesting the whole system
to begin with the one that orders and
sorts them um
you know in general rather than just
when it gets it wrong so
but no totally and also not only when it
comes to their grades right
but again if you don't really understand
how that affects
your life you i think it's harder to
make these kind of
different kind of imaginations uh on
people and and also
people you know we show how these kind
of algorithms
uh impact different kind of you know
communities of color
things like that but not all of the
people are first of all
uh encounter all of these things not
everybody
care or really understand how that can
actually influence you
in the future so um
yeah i think i saw another
yes trustee had a question i think
hi eleanor thank you for that that was
great um
i actually have a question about the
assumption that
most people have agency over things like
public demonstration right so i'm
talking about spaces and countries where
protesting is not an option you cannot
go out on the streets where digitization
is the only way for you to actually act
in resistance
and that kind of goes back to the
question in the q a it's like if the
digital is the only space you can exist
to express your freedom
express yourself then you don't really
have much of a choice and so how do you
change your narrative of data literacy
away from
cultures like the us the uk israel maybe
where you can go out and protest to
societies where you just can't do that
i think it's a really good question and
i think that yeah we have a lot of
assumptions
um in the way that um in the kind of
solutions that i was talking about as
well and this is why i said that there
is no
one solution different kind of regions
will have to respond
um in their own way i do think that um
you know there are a lot of
demonstrations
in in other regions which are not sort
of west
um based and uh they are doing it with
different kind of
means such as memes um
in different kind of ways um i think
it's going to be difficult and i think
it
it's it's i don't really know um
the exact way but i think that um
different kind of communities have
always invented creative ways
to object and to protest the way that
um things are happening um and
um they will have to use different kind
of tools
that are available i hope that it
answered
yeah but i think we definitely can't
assume that people
always have agency um
and obviously providing
people with data literacies doesn't
necessarily mean that all of them are
gonna go to the streets because
if you're poor and if you don't have the
time or money to go to the streets then
you're not gonna do that
um so of course i'm not saying this as
you know the one bullet point and you
know it's gonna free everybody and we're
gonna burn the streets and you know
but i think that um it
is a gradual um evolution of these
things
and just like you know feminism and
anti-racist uh you know groups
it's an ongoing process right we need to
keep on fighting and it's not like
everybody has the time
um or resources to do that but i think
the more
knowledge that we will have of what we
can actually do
and what kind of power we have when we
come together
i think that we can change that but of
course not everybody will be able to
participate
in these demonstrations
well great um it looks like uh
unless we have another question it looks
like we're wrapping up right on time and
so um i want to thank you again
and thank you for waiting uh for hanging
in there and
and showing up when you finally could um
it was really a really fascinating talk
and i'm glad that that we were able to
have it so um i want to thank everyone
else for who came and uh
we look forward to seeing you for having
me and uh again
i just want to remind you that the book
is open access so feel free to
check it out and also the playlist um
and i'm on twitter so if you feel like
continuing the discussion then feel free
to either dm me or email me
um and it was a real pleasure um
doing this event because you had amazing
questions
that really made me think as well which
is quite rare so
thank you very much thank you thank you
thanks